do you remember
the moment when you were like I think
I'm gonna go for this like I'm going to
try and become a senator
oh Santa
um
yeah I do remember the time I thought
about doing it and
um Paul wellstone was
um senator from Minnesota he got elected
in
um
in uh 92
and an upset Victory and he was a great
Progressive uh
Senator he's a friend of mine and two
thousand two he was running for
re-election and he was in a dead heat
with Norm Coleman and
he had to vote in October
on the Iraq War
and he was going to vote against it in
the large majority of minnesotans were
four going to war
and Paul told me
this is probably going to be the end of
my career because he was in a neck and
neck race
and he voted against it and the next
poll came out had him up by seven oh wow
went the other way because it went the
other way because minnesotans respect
a politician who votes his conscience
and his plane went down
and with Paul and his wife and his
daughter and three aides and two pilots
died
and Coleman ended up winning the race
and three months after he Norman Coleman
got into office he did a
interview with roll call which is a
Capitol Hill newspaper and he said to be
blonde I'm a 99 improvement over Paul
wellstone
and I said who the [__] is going to beat
this guy hmm
so
that's very West Wing I don't mean to
make light of this person who died or
anything but when it gets personal like
that there's a West Wing moment where
someone puts down Martin Sheen someone
who died it's almost it might have been
inspired by this for all I know and he
was like well guess what game on like
now it's personal sort of thing yeah it
did a fire under you yeah and that's not
a reason to run for the Senate I guess
but uh I moved back to Minnesota
and
um I in 2006 I just campaigned for
Democrats who were running in the state
and I found that crowds would turn out
for me
and so I decided to go for it because of
Comedy I think because of Comedy I also
written these books like Rush Limbaugh
is a big fat idiot and other
observations which was
I I've written four number one New York
Times bestsellers wow not to brag about
my phone what do you pull down for
number one huh what do you pull down for
those those are they're it's it's good
it's good
lies in the line wires is the biggest
and that uh that was about fox and fox
sued me oh wow thank you so much my wife
wanted to get a band a marching band to
go and Firefox going thank you very much
boom thank you very much why is this
thing that any I mean it was amazing
because it put so much attention there
everyone had to read yeah and they were
laughed out of court they they the title
of the book was lies and long Liars who
tell them a fair and balance look at the
right and so they sued me for copyright
or tried to stop the book from being
published because of quote copyright
fair and balanced fair and balance and
the thing is is that the case law is
clear that if you're if the thing if the
title is is something you're actually
writing about it's fine
so right they were just
laughed out of court and but O'Reilly
was so mad at me for I had made a
made him really look bad at a Book Expo
and that he insisted they sue and it was
it was a no Riley Sue they had to do it
too they had to please him yeah and I'm
uh Floyd Abrams who was number one you
know uh First Amendment lawyer in the
country took my case he'd done Pentagon
papers and all that kind of stuff
and he calls me up and he told me not to
go to court you know for it he said we
won I said Floyd a chimp could have won
this
and later there was a documentary made
about the case and he wrote and he was
interviewed he said a monkey could have
won this
and I call him up I go I did say monkey
I said chimp and he said what's the
difference like a little chimp is funny
monkey isn't
chimp a chimp even MailChimp which is a
sponsor is funny I'm just kidding
they're not a sponsor that chimp is
funnier also close and he testified once
in front of the uh I was on the
Judiciary Committee okay I wasn't I'm
not a lawyer but I played one in a
sketch that's what I like to say and uh
Floyd was satisfying and I just made him
have to I told that story or made him
you got it right on the record I got it
on the record it's in the Congressional
Record
yeah and he misquoted me
so you decide to go for it for this
beautiful reason
you get sued for your books that you
made a lot of money for then you run and
I it was a very very close race 312
votes I clobbered him there's a
narrowest clobbering in history
You collaborated by 312 books roughly an
IHOP like a full IHOP
this recount we I actually won the
recount in time to be seated with my
colleagues but the Republicans went to
court and uh delayed me like six months
but when I got there as a 60th
Democratic vote and those six years
Democratic senator so that's how we got
the Affordable Care Act and did you I
don't care for that act did you
it's good did you uh [__] act thank
God we got that thing I'm glad did you
have any imposter syndrome I mean people
have imposter syndrome for Less
for some reason I didn't and for I think
it was basically that
I knew why I was doing it
and uh and what it ceased to be you know
revenge or something but I knew I was
doing I was doing it for all the right
reasons
it's similar to your very pure and to me
sometimes challenging
just love of Comedy like you just wanted
to do comedy because you just want to
laugh and you just want to do what makes
you laugh and make people laugh that's
that's a very pure intent yeah but I
really kind of think that's any good
comedian that's that's what it is right
yeah and I'm not sure that every
politician I went goes into it for the
same reasons I hear you I went in I'm
challenged by that just because I know
when I'm off axis it's because I'm doing
comedy because it makes me high and when
I'm on access I'm and feeling good and
I'm in the flow and doing good work to
be honest it's because I'm going on
stage because I want to make everybody
laugh not for the feeling you get from
making people laugh does that make sure
that makes a lot of sense but when I I'm
with you I got into this because I want
to do what makes me laugh but then it
gets very tempting to get it's the ring
of power tolkien's ring of power now
you're like oh this gets me this gets me
off yeah then that can become your new
reason to do it right and my wife has to
recalibrate me every once in a while and
she's like okay you didn't like it but
didn't you do your job didn't you make
them laugh like you're like it's not
really about you being like I'm a Golden
Boy you know what I mean which clearly
is my wound not yours
sorry you have to live that way
put that on you in a strange moment and
what a great response
[Music]